Додому прийшла і похоронка, і місце на цвинтарі вже було.
Тобто вони вже навіть готувалися до того, щоб мене хоронити.
Була поранена. У нас вижило три людини, загиблі військовослужбовці…й це все було на очах.
Я як поранений вже потрапив на "Азовсталь", де отримав ще одне поранення в ході прориву.
Кожен із цих військових ЗСУ проходить тривалу й безкоштовну реабілітацію в Одесі.
Утім, у медзакладів кошти закінчуються, а кількість поранених, які потребують допомоги, зростає.
Рік тому Руслан потрапив під обстріл на Херсонському напрямку.
Уламки снарядів пробили військовому череп.
Без медичної допомоги Руслан пролежав десять днів.
Те, що він вижив - справжнє диво.
Медики подзвонили й сказали дружині, що я знаходжуся в лікарні.
А цих десять днів моя дружина думала, що я загинув.
У статусі полоненого у лікарні в окупованому Херсоні Руслана прооперували.
Тут він провів п’ять місяців.
Аж доки його дружина Людмила не наважилася на відчайдушний вчинок:
приїхала до окупованого Херсона і… вкрала чоловіка з полону.
Ми звернулися до завідувача відділенням, щоб документи переробити:
щоб написати не "мінно-уламкові поранення", а що це ДТП.
Він погодився, допоміг нам.
Тобто в нас були дві виписки: одна була для нас,
що ось мінно-уламкові зі мною сталися, і для них, що це була ДТП.
Ще два місяці тому Руслан не міг сидіти,
нині поволі вчиться знову стояти.
Аби повернутися до нормального життя,
знадобиться близько року регулярних занять із реабілітологом.
Утім, центр, у якому відновлюють Руслана, залишився майже без грошей.
На даний момент у нас на рахунку 7 тисяч гривень.
Це - нічого. Як ми будемо працювати далі… не зрозуміло.
Сергій Ращенко безкоштовно приймає українських військових
у своєму приватному медичному центрі.
Нині тут відновлюються близько двадцяти поранених бійців.
Як стали з'являтися перші поранені, ми увалили рішення, що будемо допомагати.
Я особисто вважаю, що вони не повинні за щось платити.
За них треба, щоб платила держава, але зараз цього механізму не існує.
Тому ми робимо це так, як можемо зараз.
У нас є благодійний фонд, ми збираємо якісь кошти, звертаємося до людей, вони донатять.
Таким чином ми з цих коштів оплачуємо роботу наших спеціалістів.
Також центр потребує нового обладнання й бодай мінімального фінансування
для обслуговування автомобіля, який безоплатно возить пацієнтів на реабілітацію.
Він спеціально обладнаний для того, щоб можна було перевозити людину у візку.
У нас є водій, потреби в бензині, всіх матеріалів потрібних,
ремонт та таке інше. Страховка, наприклад.
Всі ці кошти давали нам спонсори.
Зараз цих спонсоров майже немає.
Нині Сергій веде перемовини з потенційними спонсорами з усього світу.
І вже є перші результати.
Декілька компаній, наприклад, американська компанія "Концепт-2"
пропонує нам вибрати декілька тренажерів, які нам потрібні,
та доставити нам їх безкоштовно.
Ще ми ведемо перемовини з декількома компаніями.
Інший приватний реабілітаційний центр в Одесі також безоплатно допомагає військовим.
Цей медзаклад навіть уклав договір із військово-медичною частиною, бійцями якої тепер опікується.
Але жодних коштів від держави не отримує,
адже офіційно поранені числяться у військово-медичній частині.
Ми, маючи навіть договір з Національною службою здоров'я,
тобто маючи право отримувати якісь кошти за амбулаторну реабілітацію,
не можемо цього робити з військовослужбовцями,
бо в них є вже лікарняні у своїх військових частинах,
і ми не можемо дублювати ці послуги.
Із донорськими грошима теж халепа.
Із фондами також є проблеми.
Тобто люди більш радо дають гроші на озброєння чи на автомобільну техніку,
ніж на реабілітацію військовослужбовців. На жаль, це факт.
Тим не менше у центрі й надалі планують допомагати військовим,
адже тутешнє сучасне обладнання може поставити на ноги багатьох поранених.
Якщо казати про це обладнання, яке в нас тут є,
воно дозволяє працювати навіть з перших днів після травми та операцій.
Ми всі розуміємо - і лікарі там, і ми тут, і хлопці, які до нас приїжджають,
- що надати такі можливості, які є у мене тут, з такою кількістю фізичних терапевтів,
ці державні заклади, на жаль, на сьогоднішній день не можуть.
Ідеться не лише про відновлення фізичного здоров'я бійців, а й ментального.
Приміром, Центр психологічної підтримки Військово-морських сил України
запустив в Одесі курс іпотерапії.
Це метод реабілітації за допомогою верхової їзди.
У нас всі заняття проходять без сідла,
тобто людина сідає на спину коня і за рахунок цього вона отримує
специфічну амплітуду рухів і коливань, які робить кінь, коли йде.
Тобто кінь сам по собі повторює ходу людини.
І в нього є ще коливання в дуже різні сторони.
З боку в бік, зверху вниз і назад вперед.
Тобто ось ця амплітуда рухів має вплив і на центральну нервову систему,
і на м'язи, і на опорну рухову систему також.
Наразі курс реабілітації проходять двадцять військовослужбовців Військово-Морських сил.
Віктор отримав поранення, обороняючи порт Маріуполя.
Я як поранений вже потрапив на "Азовсталь",
де отримав ще одне поранення в ході прориву.
Медики "Азова" надали першу медичну допомогу,
наскільки це було можливо, тому що медикаментів вже тоді не було,
рентгенів не було, гіпсу не було.
Під час виходу захисників з "Азовсталі" Віктор потрапив у полон.
Без належної медичної допомоги у донецькій лікарні він пробув до обміну, який відбувся 29 червня.
Мені зробили знімки, аналізи, сказали, що все погано,
але лікувати не будемо, щоб додому поверталися каліками, щоб у стрій одразу не став.
Разом із Віктором курс іпотерапії проходить Олена Матушкіна.
Ця усміхнена жінка пережила справжнє пекло
ще у перший день російського вторгнення.
24 лютого 2022 року я попала під ракетний обстріл. І була поранена.
У нас вижило три людини.
Загиблі наші військовослужбовці.
І це все було на очах.
І це саме було тяжко, бо це був перший день, коли нас бомбили.
І через це почалися панічні атаки.
І дуже напруження було від кожного шурхоту, як-то кажуть.
І, звісно, вже рік пройшов, але воно завжди…
Це тяжко переноситься. І пам'ять не зітреш, як-то кажуть, час лікує.
Але не знаю, як це… воно досі щось не відлікувало.
Працювати з травмою Олені допомагають психологи та … коні.
Тут ти відходиш від всіх оцих... від війни, в першу чергу.
Оці півгодини, що ми займаємося на конях, то це якийсь мир настає і в душі.
І хочеться, щоб так у всіх було.
Курс іпотерації складається з десяти занять.
Для Віктора й Олени це вже дев'яте.
І спеціалісти, які супроводжують їх протягом курсу, кажуть,
що іпотерапія позитивно вплинула на їхній стан.
Тому програму вирішили продовжити.
Але в перспективі без фінансової допомоги не обійтися.
Наразі ми закінчуємо курс реабілітації першого потоку військовослужбовців,
вже на черзі запуск другої групи.
Програма реалізується за кошти благодійного фонду Військово-Морських сил України.
В планах - залучити якомога більше партнерської підтримки, ресурсу.
Проєкт планують розширити, аби допомогти якомога більшій кількості військових.